incoming bonus content
fever pitch story i didn't know i had a
crooked smile until you told me in fever
pitch i always said you have a cute
smile you talk outside of your mouth
it's in the movie but i didn't know that
until you said it i lived 28 years free
never saw anyone do an impression of you
you have this like cute you can't talk
outside of your mouth
but why was it you that made me realize
it and you improvised it yeah but i
improvised it but it made it in the
movie that people enjoyed that you
changed my life
right then
in the best way ever and now i get why
people do the impression because your
lips you move your lips around when you
talk do i have a lisp too this is pretty
cute you have a lisp as well it's very
cute you
literally hurting your back
falling off the green monster
i did boston you came down it's in the
movie you went landon you went like ah i
landed on my tailbone yes that i had
cracked during charlie's angels two days
when you had to run all the way through
fenway park to me and you were just so
out of breath of the third take you were
like
okay i remember another story i remember
flying on an airplane and we were flying
to the the the game game seven of the
world series the red sox and it was in
st louis
and i was like we were terrified but we
were gonna get to shoot on the fox
sports cameras the ending of our film if
they won they were gonna let us run down
to home plate and do a 360 kiss had the
cameras it was a fox broadcast yeah and
we were making a fox movie so we said
can we borrow a couple cameras while
we're so we because they're like you
can't bring your movie cameras to the
game yeah and we said just on one
condition you can't show that jimmy and
drew at the game on your broadcast
because that won't make any sense we're
making a movie and doing cut to we're
making out on the dugout or something
which and aired on the world series and
everyone's like what
are they dating what's going on oh and
my boyfriend at the time didn't know
and didn't know we were doing that aaron
he's like hey i got a
great text in the strokes and on tour
and i couldn't talk to him because it
was it was before cell phones yeah and i
hadn't got to him and he was like what's
going on
i was like oh god it's part of the movie
and then we went to the premiere in
london and man disappeared early that
night with you goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]
you